Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 7th,
2012 2012 baby. What's going
on? Do you guys have a,
why am I yelling? Why am
I yelling? You know why?
Cause I've got a good night's sleep and
I just had some waffles so I got dead
fucking sugar rush. Yeah, I
made, Ooh, just slam my computer.
It gives a fuck. I can't figure
out how to work in any ways. Um,
I had um, I had some waffles for
breakfast. Now why did you just shut off?
You can't.
Oh,
I see it just sorta Jesus built everything
that technology does is not an attack
on you. Why don't you just
relax? I need, hang on guys.
I just need to talk to myself
for a second. All right.
Just sit and think. Figure out what
happened. Stop taking the bait.
All right.
I'm back.
Yeah, it's in fucking waffles.
I actually made them yesterday.
I'm gonna take you guys
through my boring day.
It sounds like the beginning of a
Bruce Springsteen song, doesn't it?
Hi. Made so waffles. It was over.
[inaudible] up.
Oh my God.
How does he turn it around the
breakfast limericks from that guy.
You know what,
it's one of my goals to see him live in
concert because I've been making fun of
him forever and half of my friends had
been making fun of them and then they go
see him in concert and they were like,
dude,
you got to go see that guy in concert,
you know with his class 300 bike.
Um, he's got, he's got
a, he's got one of those.
I don't know if he was a dog. He'd be
one of those dogs with the motion faces.
You know,
he's got one of those boxer.
I'm the same dentition of
like a boxer or like a pug.
MMM.
What the fuck? Can't get done.
Pugs not breathe or something.
I know they have the motion face,
but like I always hear bulldogs have
the worst time trying to breathe,
but like pugs have the most
look of panic on their face.
Like when bulldogs can't breathe,
they just say hi,
ask gonna to fucking lay down here.
They just seem like a tub of shit dog.
We're like pugs,
like genuinely seemed concerned about
something the way their eyes bug out or do
they have like that high metabolism,
you know when you have something wrong
with your thyroid, is that the right word?
Huh? Do I have any doctors
that listen to this? Anyways,
it made waffles yesterday and the lovely
Nia is killing it and now she's working
out. She's on this. Um,
I'm going to be a fucking
even hotter chick diet. Right?
So she can't eat anything. All right.
In the end, you know the ladies, okay,
they got all that fucking hormonal shit
going on every goddamn month, you know,
stuff fucking, I dunno what,
there's always something
going on with them. You know,
they're basically, it's like living with
an addict when you live with the woman,
you know, they always got, he's
got some shit coming up, man.
They always that same bullshit.
So now you compound it with the fact,
now she's on some special diet.
So she's basically detoxing from whatever
fucking, you know how people eat,
you know, eat right. Do you get the
sugar, salt rush? The ETU totally stuffed.
You
mentally think that's what eating is.
So then when you actually eat the way
you supposed to and your body isn't like
freaking out, like
fucking Freightos, right.
It's actually just chillin with some
fucking broccoli and some protein.
You're not used to that. You know you're
used to go into some high energy shit.
So anyways, I'm sitting there making
the waffles right. And you don't,
one of those deals when you
check goes on a fucking diet.
All of a sudden you have to
be on the Diet too. You know?
Are you just doing this to torture me?
No,
I'm doing it cause I liked fucking
waffles. I felt like having some waffles.
Oh my God, I have to sit here. I have
to eat one time soup for breakfast.
Hey my fault.
You know I'm not on a diet and then they
do all that shit when they always try
to make it seem, it's easier to be a guy.
Guys can lose weight though. It's easier.
It's so much harder for women that Baba
Baba buy we you fucking outlive us.
Isn't that enough?
Isn't that enough? I'm going
to die before you do. Okay.
What is your problem with the soup?
Jesus fucking Christ Jesus Christ.
So anyways,
that's what I'm fucking dealing with.
And I actually had a major victory,
just one of those silent victories that
you have in your relationship. You know,
those are the best ones to have.
We don't say anything and you see it in
their face and you see that they realize
it and then you see them wondering if
you realize it and you kind of look back
and I'm like,
I do realize it,
but I'm not going to say it because then
you'll be able to, if I say it out loud,
just somehow fucking do some sort of two
point reversal and bring up some other
shit and then I'll lose,
you know,
I'll just fucking shoot that look right
back at you. Like that's right. Woman.
I won this one.
Okay.
You're gonna have to wait for
another fight because this one is,
oh,
okay.
It's fucking Michael Corleone
says, and the Godfather to, okay.
MMM,
I got a, I got to steal that at some
point. I want to be an argument with Nia.
I can't be a real long
cause she'll get mad.
I'm just going to do it
over something stupid.
Like she wants to go see this
cabin in the woods fucking movie.
Whatever the hell it is. It's
supposed to be a perfect movie. Uh,
what does that mean? The guy gives into
the woman? Oh Jesus. A minor fucking mood.
Can I blame it on the Syrup here?
People who was the Syrup out in Jersey?
I can't say out in Jersey.
That's Anthony's impression of him.
I owe him fucking 50 cents
right there. Some residuals. Um,
hey Anthony. Cool. Mia.
Everybody from the opiate Anthony
Program with little Jimmy Norton, um,
on Xm satellite radio. Yeah, little promo.
The fuck was I just talking about?
God dammit. Leave it on the syrup.
Ah, Shit. That thought's gone. Oh, I know.
I had this minor victory at
this minor of victory. Right?
I'm on the road hauling the root again,
right.
Doing my Dick Jokes on the road again.
I don't give a fuck
about you or your friend.
Buy My DVD and get the
fuck out of my face. Um,
I should have fucking waffles. You
know what, this little podcast,
it's going to die. And like fucking 12
minutes in, I'm just going to sugar crash.
We're going to be laying on the rug like
that fucking dude and train spotting,
but instead of like falling into it,
I'm just going to nod off like a fucking,
like a goddamn dog with a machined face.
Oh, we brought it around. What's the do?
Um, so anyways, yeah, it
was the victory I had. Um,
so I was on the road doing my jokes.
I come back to town. All right.
And uh, and is always,
somehow when I was away,
something got broken and nobody knows
as any fucking idea. It's like my car,
I don't know what happens when I take it
out. Nobody ever really hits it. Somehow.
When Nia takes it out,
somebody always hits it and then
I go out and she doesn't say shit.
I go out to use the car and I see some
side swiped down the fucking side of the
car and I just go, I come in,
I go, has somebody hit the car?
And that she's always like,
well,
when did that help?
How many times can I fall for that?
Do people just not like
you when you drive the car?
That 1:00 AM I talking about
somebody tagged it? Fuck,
a month ago when I went over Chris
Porter's somebody fucking tag my car.
Um, but anyway, so I come back and once
again something's broken. I'm the blender.
The blender was busted,
you know, the engine work,
but the little fucking teeth, things
were broken. So she's just like,
we needed a new blender.
I can't make my skinny girl Margarita
is anymore because the teeth don't work,
so let's throw it, but the fucking
motor works. So I go, well,
why don't we just get a fixed? And she's
like, oh, cause she knows what that means.
Why don't we get it fixed?
That means it's going to sit there for
three years before I finally bring it
over to a repair shop. All
right, but not, not now.
Not all new fix it Billy.
I said you know what?
I'm going to figure out how to fucking
fix that God damn thing. All I did.
You know what?
It was all like I just want it.
All you have to do is just look
up to the fucking, you get the,
I know this is basic to some people but
for a lot of morons and there's a lot
that listened to this podcast by
the way. No offense, non taken.
Um, all you do is just whatever the
brand and then the serial number.
You go on the Internet and you can,
you just buy the part.
So I buy the fucking part thinks shows up.
I do all this shit without talking
to Nia. Right? And I fucking,
I go to take this thing apart, turn it
upside down and I'm fucking pulling,
trying to pull the motor on it and we'll
come out because that thing on the top
and I'm like what the fuck?
And then he's going youtube and
I found a video of a guy doing,
fixing the problem I had.
I didn't need to unscrew the bottom.
All I need to do was just
fucking get a screwdriver and
take the thing off the top.
Which how it doesn't strip the top. I
have no fucking idea. We don't care. Bill.
Get to the point. All right. Long Story
Short, I get this fucking thing on.
It works. So what do I do? Do I get
in her face and say, yeah, a woman,
I fucking fix that shit.
I don't.
Yeah,
I don't. I fix it. Make sure it runs.
I try it out and then I just stick
it in the cupboard, you know?
And a couple of days later I go, hey, you
know what to think I'd like a milkshake.
Well, how are you going to do this? The
planner, does it work? Oh, I fixed it.
You fixed it. I fixed it. It
was no big deal. Took it apart.
I got a a fucking fix to myself. There
you go, woman. All right with your whole,
we need to fucking go buy another one.
You know,
I realize that wasn't really a major
victory even though like when you're just
in your head, do you like,
yeah, I fucking dominated.
Then I just said that out loud. That was
really no big deal. It's a seven. Does,
how much I wanted to fix it.
It was a $7 part and I had it
overnighted for like fucking 16 bucks.
So you know,
and I didn't even want a milkshake.
I just wanted to show her that I did
something. I don't know why. Why?
Because I'm a weak person and I
need other people's approval there.
Does that make you happy?
Does that make you feel,
does that make you smile
and you're fucking cubicle?
Uh Huh.
Is that what you're doing
when you were in a cubicle and you're
smiling? I've, if I was your boss,
I would immediately think that you're
somehow stealing from the company because
there's no reason to smile on it.
Pure in a cubicle, in a
computer, in a cubicle.
There's no fucking reason.
All right.
Unless you somehow figured out a way
to be happy, you know, some sort of,
when those Zen Douche bags, why they
douche though? Because they're happy.
You know what happened to you? All right.
What the fuck am I going to talk about?
I was going to do, oh, I know.
We have to talk about everybody.
This is very special.
Guess what it is this Sunday?
Mother's Day. Mother's Day. Your mom.
Okay.
The one that that,
uh,
did most of the heavy lifting is
far as bringing you into the world.
Your Dad was like the Steve Jobs. You
know, you're gay. I want this to happen.
Get on. It's scientists. Right? So
he had a part in it too, you know,
although they never bring that up on the
view. Do they? Um, believe it or not,
this is advertising. All right, let's get
on with this. A pro flowers, everybody.
Mother's Day. It's coming up. All
right? It's Monday. It's Sunday.
You know what that means?
It means it's only six days away.
So what does that mean?
That means you go down to the drugstore.
All the good cards are gone.
At this point,
they're all picked over all the
envelopes of laying on the ground.
And the only cards that are left are
either they either just, you know,
it's like a fart joke or they like
oddly incest, you, us, you know,
there's no good cards left once
again, you're screwed up. All right,
so what do you got to deal the ladies?
They liked the flowers. All right,
so here's the copy. Uh, guys,
don't mess up on Mother's Day.
If you will like me. You probably put
it through the wringer as a kid. Dui.
Uh,
now show her that you love her and send
her flowers from Plouffe. Pro Flowers.
It's a great way of making up to mom is
by sending her flowers from pro flowers.
Everybody, come on, man. You got to do
it. You got to do it. I'm going to do it.
Don't you want to be like me?
This is the deal.
You get a dozen rainbow roses from mom
plus a free glass vase for only 1,999
incredible peace and they are guaranteed
to last seven days. All right, bing,
Bang, boom. This is,
you know what's great about pro
flowers is you get to handle this.
You get to feel like what it's like to
be a rich guy. You know what I mean?
You know,
rich people are always working on their
business and they don't have time.
They don't have time to
go out and buy gifts.
So they just sent some assisted out.
Whose birthday is it? Ag Dead, dead.
Go get him a Maserati.
And you see I'm busy in here.
You can do the same thing for
a much cheaper price for 1999.
You can handle the your mom like a
rich guy running a business. What's it?
My mother, she brought me into
the world. You go out there.
Let me tell you something.
You go out there for 1999.
You get him some rainbow roses in a vase.
I'm going to get back to my job here.
All right?
This is why you've got to do,
go to proflowers.com you click on the
mic and you type in the code. B. U. R. R.
It's my last name for all the
slow people out there. And, uh,
for my radio listeners,
you can get another dozen roses
plus chocolates for just $10 more.
That's 40% off.
So there you go.
Flowers and chocolates, okay? And that
you don't have to go pick them up.
They're going to deliver them
right to a door. All right?
All you gotta do is just type in birth.
Click on the mic on the top coat top what?
Click on the mic and type in the code
bar. I can't read. All right, here we go.
Either call one 800 pro flowers.
That's it.
You can do it over the phone.
Go light up a giant cigar and act like
you're running a corporation here called
wait one 800 pro flowers or even better.
Visit proflowers.com.
Click on the microphone in the
top right corner and typing.
Berbee you are R and that's
proflowers.com and uh,
that's it. Open now for mother's Day. Oh,
order now for mother's day before
the deal is gone. All right,
before the deal is gone. Um, and
then all you got to do genetics,
that stuff shows up and then you take
out to breakfast, you give her a big hug,
you apologize for your Dui. You know,
tell her she's the best and that's it.
You've got another year
of unconditional love,
thanks to the wonderful
people@proflowers.com I
challenge you to find a better
read. Um, all right,
moving on here a little bit on what
the hell am I going to talk about? Oh,
you know, I went, I went
into a bar last night. Oh,
yesterday afternoon because the
games come on early because um,
I finally accepted the fact emotionally
that my Boston Bruins have been knocked
out of the Stanley Cup playoffs.
And uh,
okay.
I've actually, you guys know my hatred of
NBA basketball. You know, I don't hate,
I don't hate it.
I just had finals three minutes.
It drives me nuts with all the time outs.
And I know I brought it up before any,
what's even worse is when
they call the time outs.
I notice yesterday cause I watched a
game is then they start reading copy.
You know,
like anything they can do to just bring
the drama all the way back down to zero.
It's like tide fucking
98 98. Oh, they got,
they got 28 files to give and then they
followed so and sell calls a time out.
And then next thing you know, they're
sitting there reading, you know,
like what I just did
bro. flowers.com. Yes.
Your mother is some fucking, you know,
that's stupid. I don't know. So anyways,
I've accepted the fact that the Bruins
are out of the playoffs and all right,
well the bees are out. Yo, why don't
we go watch the fucking sees kid.
You know what I'm saying?
So Celtics were playing the Atlanta Hawks
who used to be the Saint Louis Hawks
and we beat them in 1958 I believe
for their NBA title. That's right.
Saint Louis. We own your ass in a sport
you don't even know about anymore.
Um, back when Eisenhower
was an office. Um,
so I watched that game and it was just a
phenomenal playoff games as far as like
being a fan because it was
over before it even started,
you know,
it was over and there was never a concern.
They were up by 30 points and I sat
there drinking beer and eating wings,
becoming fucking, oh, fat boy,
Billy again, Billy fat again.
It's my Irish neighbor.
So I'm, so I'm sitting there
right with a buddy of mine,
right watching the game.
We're having a great time and right.
And like the fourth quarter,
uh, these four girls,
four or five girls come in and it's a
dive bar. You know, I like to dive bars.
You can get as a place to sit,
you know,
it's just one of those deals.
Somebody has one of those fucking
[inaudible] character in 48 hours.
You know, they always, there's always
one of those cars parked out front,
some fucking piece of shit. Rag Top with
some sad dog in the backseat. Right?
I like those bars. You know the bar
fly car, right? So I walk in there,
we're watching the game and like
fucking with like a, I dunno,
five minutes to go in the game.
So what's that like two hours NBA time?
These like five,
six chicks come in and they're just like,
they just train wrecks all of them
wearing pants where you can just see that
clams,
you know,
ridiculously tight pants and other
girls got these cutoffs with this,
her hat turns sideways looking like she's
in some fucking fresh prince video in
the late eighties.
It just,
they were just absolute messes and they
start putting money into the juke box
and they just start singing.
They started to sing along to a video,
killed the radio star. Right. And
then they just start, you know,
and then there's all these fucking old
guys Barfly fucking Jack Offs like my age
and a little bit older, like way too
fucking old for these checks. Right.
And these girls are being
like really fucking loud. Yes.
And they're fucking dancing with each
other and they're grabbing each other's
asses, doing all this shit. And you
see these guys up at the bar, the liar,
they start like
reacting to this sex fucking energy
depth they're putting out there.
So two of the girls stand up. They
started, that's what it got dude.
It was like the fucking accused,
like times five was going down.
The whole vibe was fucking ridiculous.
So the two girls stand up,
they start like dancing,
grinding up against each other,
and then one of the guys eventually like
some big fucking sex star bear starts
walking over and starts pawn at the
girl. And then the girl's like, hey,
knock it off. Get the
fuck Outta here. Right.
And my buddy classic looks at me and goes,
she facilitated that entire fucking
thing. And it's like, exactly.
Fuck. It was a, I don't
know if there was strippers,
I don't know what the fucking deal was,
but um,
it was just one of
the thing that I've always said,
we got to have responsibility
for your own fucking safety.
Obviously that guys shouldn't just feel
that he should be able to walk over and
start pawn at some girl.
But you know,
when you sit in there with your clam
fucking outlined on the front of your
fucking jeans and you're grinding up
against her, your friend and your polling
or jacket off and she's going, stop it,
stop it, and you keep
pulling it off. I mean,
what the fuck do you think's
going to happen? You know,
I fuck.
You know,
there's nothing worse than when people
act like the world is a perfect place.
And then they act shocked when
something bad happens. It isn't. Okay.
There's the way you wish the
world was and the way it is,
so fucking act accordingly.
You don't go in there with your fucking
hoo ha hanging out and start grinding up
on your friend in front of fucking five
drunk guys who were women haven't done a
double take at since the fucking,
I dunno,
Fernando Valance, weightless
struck out the side. Okay,
sign the wrong people. It was just, it
was a really fucking uncomfortable vibe.
And I looked at my phone, I go, look, we
don't get out of here in three minutes.
We're going to be testifying in about
fucking six weeks for whatever bullshits
about ready to go down.
And you know what kills me is no one at
the bar stop them from doing what they
were doing.
You know,
I was trying to think what the fuck and
male version of what they were doing
would be.
I guess it would be like acting aggressive
and almost causing like a fight vibe.
All right. But you know, then you
get tossed out. But women could,
can create the accused vibe and uh,
I dunno,
I'm probably going to get shit
for this, but like, you know,
I'm not advocating what that guy did
that what Jack Guy Did was fucking wrong,
but Jesus fucking Christ.
What did your dad do?
Did He vote by like Fisher price? How
to be a whore? Did they make like a,
remember those little fucking stereos
they made? Did they make like a fucking
okay.
The whore version of that? I
Dunno, I'm at that age. People,
I'm at that age where I look at women
like that and I don't go like, well,
there's an easy mark. I now look at
them, go and like God, Jesus Christ.
What a fuck was your dad?
What didn't he do? Um,
but anyways,
what was actually funny was for some,
this is how drunk they were as they
were grinding on each other and fucking
pulling up each other's dresses
and doing all this shit.
The fucking for whatever reason,
uh,
out of nowhere they just started
singing the star spangled banner
and then the guys at the bar
joined in and I have video of it.
I'm going to send it to my guy and
hopefully we'll get it up on the site.
I got it like halfway through
they sang the whole fucking song.
And what was funny was that whole
fucking is somebody going to get raped,
vibe went out the window,
both sides for like a good three minutes.
We're in harmony with some sort of support
the troops vibe just out of fucking
nowhere. And I, this is the
funniest thing about it.
This was probably like
seven in the evening.
This is how fucking wasted everybody was.
Um, all right, plowing ahead here. Um, oh,
whatever women,
what do you think about that?
Am I being the fucking caveman there?
I'm not advocating that.
I'm saying that those guys, what they
did was right, but like you can't
I that's like, it's like me,
like I've always said this.
That's like me walking through central
park at like three in the morning dress
like Liberace singing.
I'm in the money.
Oh Man.
The money at that photo.
Fucking cash in my back pocket.
Right?
Someone comes up, smashes me over
the head. I get a concussion.
I got fucking my cheekbones fucked up.
You know,
they take my wallet and all
that Shit. Does it wrong? Yes.
Do you feel bad from a yes,
but what the fuck was I thinking?
Yeah.
You know,
why don't you just fucking give yourself
a bunch of paper cuts and junk jumping
shark infested water and then fucking
go and then it bit my leg off.
You're an asshole. That's bad.
That's, that's my side of it.
Relationship Advice. Follow up.
Success Story. Dare is Derris billion.
You may or may not remember a couple
months ago I emailed you about some
relationship advice.
To recap, 22 years old,
been with my girlfriend for seven
years. Most of it long, distant,
smallest things that
happened from time to time,
which made me doubt I could trust her.
I gave the example of the Strip poker
thing she lied about and the business trip
where she said a coworker
tried to kiss her. Oh yeah.
I gotta be honest with you dude. I
get a lot of emails like that. So, uh,
and I, I've been that guy. I was
that guy when I was 23. Um, anyways,
he goes, you sent me a very
clear message, pull the rip cord.
I'm just writing to let you know that I
did take your advice and although it was
probably the hardest thing I've ever
had to do was 100% the right call.
So thank you for giving me
the extra nudge I needed.
Hopefully in the future I can be a fucking
man about these things and you just
do what needs to be done. Um, through
most of the relationship fall out.
Now I did have to tell her to get
fucked when she kept wanting to get back
together.
She didn't seem to understand that all
of the reason we broke up would still be
their bottom line. I'm happier than I've
been in a long time. Thanks man. Oh yeah.
Well there you go.
And that's the hardest thing too,
is when they're coming back to you because
as you're thinking is your brain up
top is going. This is
wrong. You're out. Stay out.
Your Dick is going Free
Pussy, dad, Jeffrey
all wants to fray policy. All
right, that's what you dick saying.
So you have to override that. And
uh, I got to be honest with you,
the only reason why she was getting back
with you was just to get with you till
she was mentally prepared to walk away
from you so she could pull the ripcord
and uh, that's the worst. So you avoided
all of that. So now this is what you do,
son.
Um,
go out and have a good time and don't
get involved with anybody that you don't
feel you're going to marry. All right?
Is this the mother of my kids? All right.
Go Fuck Yourself. And that's how you
do it until you meet the one that is.
And then that's the one that's
the one you gave your heart to.
But other than that, fuck all
of them. Fuck them. All right?
I don't mean that misogynistic
way, but just, you know,
when you fucking, you know,
two, three dates in and the day, it
doesn't feel fucking weird. You know,
it's this start, it doesn't feel
right. I mean it's still feeling weird,
you know,
at that point,
all she has at your place is maybe a
scrunchie or some sort of fucking a
toiletry. The just getting this out, dawn,
you go beat it and you don't have to
be mean. You just be honest. Just say,
listen, I, I really like
you. You're a nice person.
I just don't see this a longterm.
So rather than waste your time and my
time and then I suppose getting really
hurt,
we'll just just leave right now.
I believe this
does yours.
Um, all right, good for you sir. Good for
you. All right, here we go. Pissed off.
Bay Area Fan. Who Mice,
who's also might be cops.
What? All right, thanks for
canceling the Sunday show. San Jose.
You Ginger. Fuck. Oh yeah, I'm doing San
Jose coming up and I had to, I couldn't,
I can't do the Sunday show.
I had to cancel that one.
So evidently this guy says at least 10
of us bought tickets to the show and as a
boozy and had a boozy work night
night out, planned around it, uh,
to say we were looking forward
to it would be an understatement.
We are not some random group of
amateurs either. We are dedicated fans,
faithful podcasts,
listeners,
we came out to see you last time you were
in San Jose and we even stood in line
to meet you, uh, by,
by the DVDs and buy the DVDs.
Man. Some of us were even women.
And not only that, we actually,
we've actually been polarized,
polarizing on behalf on your
behalf and one you several,
several new fans who also bought
tickets to the Sunday show.
One guy's bitch wife only allows him out
one night per year and this was going
to be his 2012 hour in Jesus
Christ. Dude, you're killing me.
We've told him you're a standup guy.
How do we tell him you've thrown us
over and are scurrying out to Chicago to
suck up to Vince Vaughn.
Douche. Move Mr Burr. Douche.
Move.
Hey,
what about the other two nights?
I'm going there. First of all,
stop acting like San Jose.
It's like some blue chip fucking city.
All right. San Jose only can
look down to Bakersfield.
You look in eye to eye at Sacramento.
All right?
You're both the chicks with the
good personalities. All right?
But we all know the Hottie
is San Francisco. Okay,
listen, I apologize. It's
something I have to do. Um,
it, it'll make sense in a few months.
It'll make sense in a couple of months.
Why had do what the fuck I'm doing?
I don't talk about the shit that I,
that I'm doing because most of it get,
doesn't get picked up.
It gets swatted back down to the ground.
So why fucking bring up, oh, hey,
I just did this.
And allegedly it has the opportunity
to do that and then nothing happens.
And then it's bad enough.
It doesn't happen.
Then you have to deal with people going,
hey, whatever happened to that thing. Oh,
if it failed, it crashed. Didn't
burn. So, uh, I, yeah,
I have to go to Chicago. It's a
fucking loyalty thing. All right.
You think I wouldn't like to spend
another fucking night in San Jose?
I love San Jose. I don't like this shy.
I don't like you. You're a hockey team.
I respect your fans though. You've
got great fans up there, so I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Julie, Jim, Dave, Mikey,
Joey, Joey's girlfriend, Rico, Bill,
and several others. All
right, you fucking babies.
Um, and he goes, no, we can't. Oh,
let ps, no, we can't just come Friday,
Saturday shows instead because we work.
Those nights were in a local
law enforcement. Oh Shit.
They have guns. Um, yeah,
my fault. I'll make it up to you and
I'll see at the policeman's ball. Um,
there's no way we can get the night
off Saturday, Sunday night. Was it man?
All right. All Right Joe, over what
you think? I'm not coming back.
Shit. You know what? You're good.
You got me with the guilt. You did.
You got me with the guilt. Hey, how
about those La Kings? Everybody's.
Anybody else watching
of the fucking playoffs?
The La Kings for the first time since
the Gretzky era. And as far as I know,
I didn't look this up. I think only
the second time when their history,
they've made it to the
western conference finals,
at least as far as when
I've been paying attention.
I don't ever remember him there.
Back when they had those yellow
and purple Laker jerseys on.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno. And the country
devil's keep beating the flyers.
I thought the flyers. I'm not saying
it's over. God knows it's not over.
When it's a fucking flight. It came
back down. Oh three against my Bruins.
Um, but the devils are
just so fucking country,
you know what I mean?
And I mean that with all due respect,
I hate it when they played the
trap and all that type of shit. But
sons of bitches, man, they played very,
they played like dead disciplined hockey,
right? Disciplined. Um, I don't know.
All right, let's plow ahead here. What do
we got? What are we get next? All right,
Dell. Is it racist, racist,
racist. Machinic addition.
Um, what is this man? Fuck a machinic.
It's a Murdoch owned paper.
Enough said.
What is machinic?
What the fuck?
What is this throwback? Is
it racist? Machinic edition?
I have no idea what this means.
It says as long as the nets are allowing
Jz to call their marketing shots.
What a shock that he chose black and
white as the new team colors to stress as
the nets explained their new urban home.
Why not have him apply
the full Jz treatment?
Why the Brooklyn Nets when they,
they can be the New York words.
What the fuck is this?
The cheerleaders should be the Brooklyn
bitches or hoes team logo.
A nine millimeter.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, this is Phil mushed. Nick.
Oh, filled, mushed. Nick wrote this.
Oh, okay. Phil Mutchnik is this guy
who's just, he's never in a good mood.
He could be getting a two on one on a
sunny day in the middle of winter and he
would still find a reason
to complain about stuff.
And that's funny coming from me because
I'm one of the biggest concern over was
all right,
Phil Mutchnik.
This is what he wrote about Jay z
owning the nets in um, Brooklyn. Okay,
now I get it.
He says,
as long as the nets are along Jay
z to call their marketing shots.
Well why shouldn't they? It's America.
He had the money, but the team, uh,
what a shock that he chose black and
white as the new team logos to stress as
the nets explain their new urban home.
Okay.
Why not have them apply the
full Jz treat treatment?
Why the Brooklyn Nets when
they could be the New York,
New York and words that Shelia is,
could be the Brooklyn
bitches or hoes team logo.
A nine millimeter with hollow
tip shell casings strewn beneath.
Want to be JC hip than go
all the way. Ah, Jesus.
That's just stupid. Well, isn't black
and white? Isn't that inclusive?
Okay.
Like there's only black and white
people in Brooklyn, but I'm just saying,
you know why st nine millimeters is a
whole Hasidic population. There's the,
uh, growing up Gadi Oh,
population out there.
Okay.
Brooklyn is a,
okay.
Oh, Phil, I think he is, he just,
anyways, he says, Bill, is this racist?
There's this Asian girl that I work with
who has a bit of an eye condition that
is slowly, oh, this is
a whole different thing.
Ah,
I love this guy was tying that in. I'm
sorry, I'm just a fucking idiot right now.
I told you the Syrup it's was wearing off
the sugar rush or whatever his fucking
wearing down here.
MMM.
Yeah. Why did he do that? Is
he trying to be the next, uh,
who's that guy with the cowboy
hat? Yeah. Wow. That guy.
Um,
he's mad that their,
that their colors are black and white.
What is wrong with black and white?
It's not like the nets
had a classic uniform.
I thought then they're uniform
was hideous. They had that,
that gray with the red
and the White was awful.
I think it's cool that there's a team
in Brooklyn. Oh, Phil Mush. Nick,
why don't you go get yourself a Sunday?
You have miserable bastard. All right.
Coming from me. All right, Bill,
is this racist, racist, racist? Uh,
there's this Asian girl that I work with
who was a bit of an eye condition that
is slightly but definitely noticeable.
She's not cross out. She's not cross side,
but something is definitely a skew.
You can tell she's looking at you,
but one I kind of drifts off into
no man's land. Yeah. Lazy Eye.
Now normally Google, Google the eyes
would be a pretty big turnoff. Right.
But she almost seems more
are learning because of it.
This had me wondering if Asian women
can pull off this look better than other
nationalities.
Uh,
a mainstream example of
this would be Lucy Lu.
She had set an eye thing going on.
I'll be it a slight thing,
but she's revered as a hottie.
Compare that to a Caucasian
Bobby. Bobby Bet. Sia,
the CNN anchor that Nancy
Walls did an impression of,
or African Americans.
Stuart Scott.
Okay.
A lesser example.
He's a male.
Is it racist of me to believe Asian may
have the edge when it comes to public
overlooking their lazy eyes?
If so,
do you think it's due to their eyes
being almost that's detracting from the
wonkiness?
Ah, Jesus. Dude, I think you
just think this girl is hot.
You know, when you'd rather
bang her then Stuart Scott,
I think it's really that simple.
Um,
I don't know who know who
half those other people are.
I don't watch CNN or
Fox News. I find it, uh,
I don't know.
I just find both those, they're totally
slanted and opera sit direction.
So I never watched that shit.
And that Stuart Scott is
battling a for his life.
I believe so. Uh, I dunno dude.
I think you just want to fucking,
I think he just, I just think
you want to bang this girl. Um,
I think that's why you've,
I think you like Asian chicks regardless
of whether their eyes are looking at
you are not looking at you. You, you like
them. So, you know, when I say sir, I say,
go for it.
You know,
go get yourself a beautiful girl.
it's great she can buy them because we
will do what I was gonna do an easy jokes
that I'm not doing it.
All right.
Okay. Here we go. Bill. Uh,
want to bang lesbian friend
who was in lesbian remission.
Okay.
Jesus. Okay, this is outside my realm, but
I'll, I'll try and answer it. Hey Bill,
I want your opinion on this problem.
I have.
I'm a 19 year old college freshman and
I'm in a bit of an ethical dilemma.
I have this friend who was a
lesbian and recently she has been,
she hasn't been having
any luck with the ladies.
Okay?
So now she's feeling vulnerable
to the point that she's active,
actually contemplating about fucking this
guy. She knows after she tells me this,
I start getting jealous because I've
always had sexual feelings for her,
but never acted on them because she's
a lesbian and I respected her dude.
What kind of a fucking asshole are you?
You know,
why are you hanging out with her?
We were just waiting for daylight. What?
What are you doing? She's a lesbian.
She doesn't want to fuck you.
You
just sitting in an edit yet. It's a
dried up wealth. It's over. Walk away.
What else does it, well, I
guess she's a lesbian. Maybe
she's into some. Uh, I dunno.
Did she fix cars like you?
I have no idea what that,
ah, is there anything worse
than a guy just hovering around?
You know, rather than going out and just
like, I dunno what you're waiting for.
Just plenty of fish in the sea
in 19. Well, but you know what?
I'm being too hard on you. You're 19
years old. You have no idea how Cleo,
can you help me out with this
one? Oh, you got to go real quick.
You got to go.
This guy's trying to bang this lesbian
girl who was in lesbian remission.
It means she hasn't, she's wanting to
like hook up with some other ladies,
but they're not given it to her.
She'll,
she's actually been contemplating
fucking this other guy.
So now this dude's jealous cause
he's always been hanging around her.
I mean that conversation we had earlier.
That's why guy guys hanging around.
Women, either the gay guy or
they're trying to fuck you.
There's really no other discipline. All
right. Why wish you could hang here?
All right, cool. Have Fun. Huh? All right.
That's nice stuff. Your fans thought that
you were coming on and now you're not,
you're leaving them wanting more.
You'll, you'll leave them wanting more.
Can we do this real quick? It
has to be very quickly. Okay.
So I told you what's going on. Yeah,
I'll get out of here. Um, anyways,
but now that she's in the mood to
go to going back to fucking dudes,
some other Douche is feeling her up.
Even before I knew what was happening.
So this other guy got in there.
He goes,
I don't want to make her my book
girlfriend. We both made it very clear.
Neither of us are good at being in
relationships because we're both selfish
people. I did not want, however,
I do want to fuck her once,
and I tried asking my cousin for
his point of view on the situation,
but he recently found Jesus,
so the only answer is to give.
He gives me his read the Bible
or premarital sex is a sin.
What do you think?
Should I sleep with her before she fucks
this guy and realize she doesn't like
men and ruin any chance? I
have a wait. Should I try?
Oh, should I try to sleep with her before
this guy fucks her and she realizes she
doesn't like men and ruin any chance
I have or should I just go just be the
friend and do nothing.
Thanks.
Are there no other women around for you
to fuck that you're just completely is
singularly focused on and obsessed
with this girl who's a lesbian?
That's exactly what I said. Why are you
hovering around her? That's what I want.
Is it because you can't have
her or like it's it's a,
it's a chase thing or it's a struggle
that he his leg how what it is.
I bet that the same, the same height and
they can borrow each other's clothes.
Just leave it.
I was wondering where you going to wear
that flannel to like cause I feel like
getting involved sexually with anyone
who's having like going back and forth
with their sexuality and figuring
out is probably not a good idea.
Just cause there's probably a lot of
emotional shit going on along with that
that she may not talk about
and you may not be aware of.
I would just leave it alone.
Yeah.
Why don't you just go talk to a
girl that wants to bang a guy?
Why don't you make it a lot easier?
Make it a lot easier on yourself. Hey,
how do I turn this bus into a bicycle?
I've always wanted this
bus to be a bicycle and a,
now it's a men like the chase though,
right?
The you have the layer.
We'd like a layup.
I thought men are all about the chase
and make it difficult and all that.
I thought, oh, that's
what you guys are into.
You guys are ready to
just making it difficult.
We want you guys just to fucking
just lie down or recline,
stop acting like it doesn't feel
good for you to, you know, no,
you know what it is there.
There is as far as like a,
a good feeling is when a woman is making
it difficult and you'd tear through all
that bullshit and you're
able to make her a sitcom.
It rolling your eyes in the right. You've
experienced that, haven't you? Well, yeah.
This is the speech that you give before
you tell people like, oh you, you,
you are making it difficult.
And that dude was cock blocking me
and I fucking I that was that, that,
that right there is like a,
remember that year when when Tom
Hanks went back to back Oscars,
he's still a great actor, but you know, is
that ever going to happen again? That's,
that's my, that's my uh, sexual
conquest. The night I brought you down,
brought you down like a fucking will.
The base on the Serengeti before.
You didn't have to see what they do. They
just take it away. Cleo, come on. Come on.
All right, well that's my, that's my 2
cents. Okay, so I'm gonna go now. Okay.
All right. I'll see you have fun
right there. Fucking female. Robocop.
I can work it out like a maniac.
I'm over here becoming a tub of shit.
That's right. All right, I'll see
you later. So there you go. Sir.
This is what I think you should
do. And we basically, both of us,
you've got to stop hanging out with these
girls that, uh, why are you doing that?
You know,
I know why you're doing it anyway.
They want it because you can be
like, Yo, my dick is so intoxicating.
Even chicks a don't like Dick.
Can't say no to my Dick. Oh,
um, all right, let's read
some advertising. Shall We?
People, let's get on with it.
Where the hell is it here?
Oh, Christ. Where are we?
Where are we? Okay, here we go. Here we
go. The usual stamps.com. Everybody, uh,
we've done this one before.
This is one. This is,
this is the runaway advertising
hit on the podcast here.
Everybody's getting into it. And by the
way, you know, I heard our hit her story.
Uh, Nia always listens to NPR.
She always listened to that.
All things considered. Today we're
going to talk about hoe strawberries.
You're mead for strawberry doors and
everybody, you enjoyed her. Srovio Jesus,
NPR. Good Lord. It's a fucking bore fest,
right? Um, she always has it on. So I
fucking sit there and I listened to it,
you know,
and uh,
but they were talking about the post
office and how it's bankrupt and how
they're going to be change. They're
going to be closing a bunch of them soon.
And a, at least this is what they were
saying, unless they're super busy,
they're going to be closing them.
So why don't you get the jump? Okay.
Get the jump and go to stamps.com and
bring the post office into your home,
your apartment or your cardboard box
in the sidewalk. Wherever you live in,
you can bring the post office
in the your dwelling. All right?
They're going to start closing them soon.
You know,
you want to be standing outside.
They're like that poor son of a bitch who
put all his money in the bank and when
a bank fails, he standing out
there with his little, his little,
this little card with the number on it,
but that you said it was in there.
You don't want to be that guy. Get
the job. Post offices are closing.
The Sky is falling. I'm using
fear this week. All right,
go to stamps.com everybody. Uh, what
the hell is it called? Copy is attached.
I thought I knew this one by heart.
Christ's sake. I know what it is.
You go to stamps.com
this is a great thing.
You're able to print legal
stamps with your own,
your home computer and your
printer, whoever you need.
You just bing, Bang, boom.
You do it. You can do it. Whatever hour
of the day. They give you a little scale,
you know, so if you want
to go, I don't know,
it's mother's Day coming up and you bought
something and you want to ship it out
to your mom. You know, you just put
it in a box, put it on your scale.
You weigh at bing, Bang, boom, get
done. Put it out of the mailbox.
Postman comes the next day.
It picks it up.
You don't even have to leave
your Dang house. All right.
If you act now by listeners,
get a free $110 worth the stamps and a,
you just go to stamps.com. You Click
on the microphone with the Code, uh,
B U R R burn. Um, I'm
telling you this guy,
this is actually is now a more viable
than ever considering they're actually
closing the post offices,
the offices where they post.
Um, and that's it. Game Fly
gameplay.com is another one.
Do you know what I noticed yesterday
when I was watching the NBA? They out.
They did pro flowers and the did gain
fly.com and I was thinking, you know what,
the NBA, they listening to
my podcast of ripping me off.
They have the same
advertises. Um, gamefly uh,
so you keep it short this week.
This is up to you if you want
to do this any more or not.
Ah, what are you talking about? Why
would I want to keep doing this?
I love game fly.com you get 8,000
video games at your fingertips.
I guess that was an inside note
like I wasn't supposed to read that.
Gave slide.com everybody. Do you
like video games? Sure. We all do.
How would you like to have 8,000
video games at your fingertips?
It can either be delivered
right to your gay,
right to your house or you can download
them right on your own damn PC.
You get a 15 day free trial,
15 days. You can stay at home,
use all your sick days, your
vacation days, played video
games. Go to gamefly duck.
Thank gave light dot.
Yeah,
calm slash bar and you'll have access to
all of those day you go. How was that?
Those raids? All right. Um, hey,
remember she wakes up and telling you
guys how I've been trying to get into
learning how shit works and science
and all that because I have such a poor
science background.
I have a youtube video of
the week and it basically,
it explains,
um,
how a differential works
on your truck or your car.
And it actually fucking blew my mind.
Now the weird thing about this video
is for some reason the first like six
minutes of it,
you have to sit through a policemen on
motorcycles doing all these different
formations and these x game tricks,
it's a from like the 1940 so it
has that world war two propaganda,
you know, and uh, you know,
they're holding onto each other's arms.
They're standing up riding around this
whole little fucking Hitler youth sort of
beginning thing.
It's really weird,
I guess at one point when the going around
and trying to show the principles of
a car going around the corner
in the differential, but
it's fucking amazing. Um,
and I know a lot of you guys like bill,
I don't give a fuck.
I don't want to learn how to fix my car.
And you know,
when I say yes should do the,
Becky had this no way.
When you bring your car down
to the dealership and you know,
it's something simple but
you just never read up on it,
there's no way you don't feel like a
bitch when you sit in there, you know,
telling you I, you know, I didn't
realize about the differential.
I didn't realize that,
uh, it, it also allows,
I know it took all the torque from
the engine and made it go 90 degrees,
but I didn't realize
it gave you back tires,
the ability to turn independently.
That's what blew my mind because it never
dawned on me that when you go around
the corner,
the inside tire has to go like wait a way,
shorter distance than the outside tire.
So if they're both turning at the same
time, one of them would be sliding.
I don't know which one. But,
so I guess that makes sense.
But for them to figure out a gear as
to how to get those things to turn
independently. It's just, it's fucking, it
just, you just got to watch it. All right?
And if you watch it,
you're going to be like make and you're
going to get fucking obsessed with it.
And you're going to buy the owner's
manual to your fucking car that is about a
thousand pages thick and
you're going to finally like,
I've actually looking at like explosion
drawings of like transmissions and,
uh, my whole life I had no idea what
a fucking transmit should look like.
Is this boring the shit out of all of you?
Well,
can I learn something though?
I gotta be the sports talking more
on for the rest of my fucking life.
Um, hey, how about those
New York Knicks? Everybody,
they finally want to play
off game. Congratulations
to all New York Knicks fans.
Unless you liked the Yankees, then
you can go fuck yourselves. Um,
ended a 13,
a 13 game in a row.
Play off game losing streak.
I want to know what do you guys think?
When will that ever get beaten?
That's going to,
that one's going to stand for awhile.
I was actually tried
to do the math on that.
In order to duplicate
that best case scenario,
you only get swept two years in a
row or two playoff trips in a row.
Like best case scenario would be you,
uh,
were up three games to none one year,
and then you lost four in a row,
so you didn't get swept
and this four losses,
then you get swept two more
times in a row. That's 12.
And then you lose the first game. And the
next one, that's the best case scenario.
The fucking,
Nick's lost
some playoff series when van Gundy was
still there. They lost the last two games.
So that was their first two loss.
Then they got swept that six,
they got swept again. That's 10. Then
they lost the first three of this one.
That's 13. I swear to God, if they
lost yesterday, that 14, you would,
they go.
Only way somebody could beat that.
You'd have to get swept three times in a
fucking ruts, practically impossible. Um,
and this is what kills me is Paul Versey,
Old Jersey.
[inaudible] New Jersey Zone,
the pride of fucking red bank.
He fucking,
we got in this huge fucking debate.
He fucking annoys the shit out of me
with his praise of Madison Square Garden.
Like he feels like,
like this venue,
like that is the most
overrated fucking venue,
I think in professional sports because
it gets so much fucking cloud because
it's in New York City,
the Paris of the United States,
and just because it's fucking there
that everybody seems to forget the
incredible lack of championships
that have been one there. Okay.
The fucking New York rangers have one,
one Stanley Cup since 1940
that's 72 fucking years.
There's been one championship,
one there.
The New York Knicks haven't won since
fucking Nixon resigned 40 fucking years.
All right,
and this dude is telling me ego first.
He's always talking about how Jordan
said that was his favorite place to play
and he uses,
this is out of the fight started.
He told me that fucking the garden during
game three was the loudest NBA game
he's ever heard. And I'm like, really?
Do you really think that it was louder
than the Boston Garden or the La Forum
when the Lakers and Celtics
were playing a game?
70 you really think it was louder.
Game three,
Nick's verse the heat and
you're down fucking two.
Do you really think the venue was
fucking louder? I mean, what do you base?
And he goes, dude, this isn't about
championships. I'm like, it's not,
I'm not saying it's about championships,
but we were playing for championships
so you're going to be even amped up even
more.
And he just keeps saying how they use
that stupid fucking expression that that
that Madison Square Garden,
it's a mecca.
It's a mecca for basketball and
it's what people don't understand.
I don't the understand what Mecca just
meets people from around the world
gathered there to gathering
place. It's like if, if,
if Madison Square Garden was in a mall,
it would be a food court.
People gathered from all over the mall.
Some people came there to buy a dress,
other people came there to buy a
slack by some slacks, but they,
they all in the food court
to eat that shitty food.
And yes,
it is a basketball Mecca.
People gather from around the globe to
kick the next fucking ass every year if
they make the goddamn playoffs.
All right.
It's just fucking annoys the shit out of
me because I give it up to the Yankees
forum like, like that, that, that's,
that's the top team in baseball.
It's not even close.
27 championships.
Right.
And he's going to fucking sit there and
he's going to try and talk about Madison
Square Garden.
Like this is the crown jewel of the
fucking NBA and completely disregard the
Celtics and Lakers who combined
have one 32 NBA championships Putts,
the Lakers BBA championship that they
count as an NBA championship for 33 and
you're sitting on fucking too. All
right. I gotta be honest as an outsider,
when I think of Madison Square Garden,
I think of Muhammad Ali,
I think of led Zepplin Mark Messier.
Yay.
Casually.
I'll think of a Bernard king,
Frank Sinatra, a Bruce
Springsteen, a rolling stones.
I think more music.
I don't think sports because
nothing really fucking memorable.
What has ever happened there?
I don't understand what
has happened at the Bruins.
Went into the stands and
somebody got beaten with a
loafer. Mike Millbury, right.
That's a rat them out.
But I mean it's on video Mike,
and we just don't understand. Like I, it
just, I just tried to tell him, I'm like,
dude, it's not louder. It's not louder.
You think it was louder than when the
Celtics finally one another fucking
championship after their drought of
like whatever, what it was 22 years.
Do you really think it was louder than
that? I was trying to explain to him.
It just seems loud to you because
you're a Knicks fan. You know?
It's like that dude who was into the
Asian women and he's gone out to do,
they play off the lazy eye.
You just see like Asian women,
it's the same fucking thing.
All right,
so just in case there's some
more verses out there. Okay.
You have a nice little venue down there.
It's,
it was made during the cookie cutter time.
Some of the worst fucking venues ever.
The ceiling is ugly and a, there's an
unbelievable, I've done this job before.
I always talk about the,
the breeze and Madison Square Garden is
an unbelievable breeze up in the rafters
because there's no championship
banners to block the air conditioning.
So anyways, having said that,
congratulations to the next, um,
if the next ever went on a run and we're,
uh,
a championship team,
even then,
the best that they could hope
to do is duplicate what, uh,
the Bulls did with Jordan when,
when they were the center of the
basketball universe. But in my lifetime,
they never have been.
And I'm an old fuck
man. I've been around for
a long time at this point.
I'm halfway through this journey if I'm
lucky. Hopefully only halfway through.
Um, so there you go. I went out of
my way to trash the fucking next,
even though they just fucking one.
Um,
okay.
I don't, and I don't even
know shit about fucking a,
I don't know shit about basketball.
Why don't I just shut the hell up?
What am I up to here? 56
minutes. All right, let's read
some more advertising here,
right? amazon.com everybody.
Hey, do you like me? Do you
like my podcast deal? Well,
if you don't,
do you like the troops I'm drafted behind.
You're like of the troops.
This is the deal. Um,
next time you go to amazon.com not saying,
yeah,
but next time you're
gonna to buy something,
why don't you just go to bill [inaudible]
dot com. Click on the podcast page.
That thing opens up on the right hand
side. You're gonna see the Amazon banner.
You Click on that thing and then
just go buy something if you want to.
And when you do,
you'll be supporting my podcast because
I get a kickback and 10% of whatever
kickback I get from amazon.com I throw
to the wounded warriors project c support
my podcast and you support the troops.
How about that? Can you beat that?
I don't think you care.
So, um, I think that's it.
I think that is the, uh, the
podcast for this week. White.
There's some overrated under
Raiders. Remember those things, um,
underrated and a pissing in the shower.
One of the most relaxing
things you could ever do. Grow.
Just lean back,
hands free,
and just let go of all your worries.
Trust me. Sounds gross. It's
what he's, but it's awesome.
Plus it all goes down the same pipes and
this way you'll save a flush worth of
water. It's like the
hybrid of toilet time. Um,
it doesn't go down the same pipe.
It doesn't go down the same
fucking jackass. It doesn't.
The toilet goes down your
fucking sewage line. All right.
They don't all,
they don't all flush together.
Tell me they don't all flush together.
Then where does that water go to then
get treated and then I wash my hair with
the shit.
We all shit and pissed in a probably
does this so many fucking people.
Does it go down the same fucking line
now?
Now it would do you would the smell
of shit would become and write up your
shower drain?
Maybe.
Eventually it does.
I don't think it does.
I thought they kept those two separate.
Wow.
That's fucking disgusting. Can somebody
please write me and clear that up? Um,
anyways, frosting your own beer
glasses at home. Underrated apps.
A fuckin lutely. And by the
way, you're required to do that.
Okay. If, if you say, hey, you guys want
to watch the game at my, you are required
to frost up some glasses.
Okay?
That's a, that's one of the unwritten
rule. You know, there's unwritten rules.
You don't show up a pitcher.
You know what I mean?
After the whistle blows,
you don't shoot the puck at the goalie.
Those fucking unwritten rules.
Okay.
You know,
the unwritten rule is that you have
your buddies over to watch the game.
He got a frost
glasses,
you know,
and then get mad at them when
they pee all over the seat.
Overrated. A giant Oprah style
mansions with 20 bedrooms and shit.
I grew up pretty poor and
it's some small houses.
And I remember thinking as I was
watching those screen movies,
how that Shit could never
happen to broke people.
They had the rich kids in these
giant ass houses, giant ours houses.
This guy must be from Europe here.
Um,
and people getting murdered in some other
room while the rest of the people were
oblivious,
which made me laugh as growing up.
I could hear my mom in the kitchen
walking around on the wooden floor.
What while I was in the bedroom, literally
on the opposite side of the house.
No Way.
Some Mass Douche is slaughtering someone
d masking and then walking back into
the lounge like, hey guys, what I
miss? Uh, so sleek, tight there,
Richie rich.
That's fucking hilarious.
But you know what's crazy
about those houses is,
you know when you have like 20 bedrooms,
you don't think about it.
But like those rooms are useless.
20 bedrooms. So you got to go out and
buy 20 beds. What can you do on your bed?
Sleep and fuck,
right?
Do you need to do then a bunch
of other rooms other than that,
how long does that take?
For me,
sleeping in fucking takes eight hours
and seven minutes on a good day.
Right? So other than that,
it's just a useless room.
Okay.
I, I you need whatever,
three, four bedrooms. And
then after that everybody can,
you know, go sleep in the family
room, go sleep in the movie room,
go sleep in my study. You want to
turn those rooms into something else?
I've never understood.
Uh,
yeah,
I don't know. You don't
want to be, see, I, I,
this is why I think those people
live in those kinds of pieces.
Some people just want a giant house,
but there is got to be
something really comforting
to live in. Like the Illuminati
is like culdesac you know,
like if I ever became like,
just like some fucking billionaire,
you know,
which I really think is inevitable with
the wild success of this podcast and all
this advertising that pretty soon,
you know,
I will become a billionaire.
Um,
I go fuck yourself,
whatever, whatever. I say,
I invent the next fucking APP for the
iPhone and I make a zillion dollars. So,
you know, there's gotta be something
comforting when the dollar is crashing.
If you're in this giant gated fucking
community with its own security.
Ah, Shit. Even then, even then, any,
you gotta think the Security Guy?
I would make friends with the security
people, like ridiculous friends.
I would like if I had that kind of money,
I would pay off the houses.
Well then he wouldn't
fucking show up to work.
I'd have to do something where
they were on my side. You know,
I just make a plant dude, when
it, when the shit goes down,
you could bring you and your family
and your pistol to my house. All right.
I have fucking 10 years worth of beef
in my fucking 4,000 square foot fucking
refrigerator.
Okay.
Freezer,
we can eat for 10 years.
All and I have enough bullets for
you to hold people off. Can you,
can you do this? Are you willing to do
this or that? That's how I would plan.
I would have my own little mini militia.
You know,
I don't buddy my told me
one time they were having,
they had this fire in the
Hollywood hills somewhere out here.
Can somebody please find me footage of
this because I refuse to believe that
somebody had this level of wealth,
but it sounded awesome.
Where the big thing about if when
you live in the hills out here, um,
this is basically what happens all right?
Every year for like a month straight if
fucking it seems like it rains every day
out here.
And during that time all the hills turn
all green and they're beautiful and
they're lush and all that type of shit.
And then after that,
occasionally it will fucking rain.
So what happens is gradually the hills
start to dry out and then towards the end
of the year, the Santa Ana winds
come in off of the desert. All right?
And it's just flat.
So they come in and like fucking sometimes
upwards of a hundred miles an hour
and it's like nature's hairdryer and
it just dries out all of the hills and
turns them this shitty.
Jesus has common brown.
And then eventually something happens,
somebody throws a cigarette out the
window. I don't know what I dunno. Fuck.
A rattlesnake takes a shit
and hits a piece of Flint.
I don't know how these things work.
I have a bad science background,
whatever the fucking things catch on fire
and all these rich motherfuckers that
you're jealous of during those months,
you're not jealous of when you watch
their fucking houses burned down.
So one time a buddy of mine was saying
he was watching the news and somebody had
so much fucking money.
Daddy,
the dude had his own fire
department basically.
And these guys were on top with these
fucking fire retardant suits and these
giant like,
like cannons that were shooting foam
all over the perimeter and all over the
house.
So his house didn't burn down and like
the four houses around a burn to the
ground and his house was fine just
sitting in this giant mountain of fucking
shaving cream and a,
yeah,
I just remember thinking that,
that it, that is dead is the shit.
Like if I was wealthy, that's what
the fuck I would do. You know,
I wouldn't help the less fortunate,
I would make sure that I could protect
all my shit. Wouldn't, you know,
that was a nice little selfish moment.
But I am, I'm selfish son of a bitch.
That's the podcast for this week. Hey,
would you guys like to see me do stand up?
Well, why don't you go to [inaudible]
dot com like I'm doing right now.
You fucking bastard. Where the
hell is it? There we go. Uh,
these are some of the upcoming shows.
I am going to be in loss hung delays at a,
at a club called flappers.
I swear to God it's called
flappers in Burbank.
I'm trying to build up my new act and uh,
on May 25th,
I don't even have the data from my
website yet. I'll have to get it up there.
A place called flappers in
Burbank, California. Um,
other things I have coming up.
San Jose, I'm going to be a,
at the Improv on the 15th and the 16th.
Unfortunately I had to cancel the show
on Sunday and a on the Sunday I'm going
to be at the Chicago theater
June 17th.
And uh, then the Ontario,
Ontario Improv, the 29th,
30th and July 1st. Jesus Christ is
something that wears this summer.
Go and Hampton Beach Ballroom
Casino in New Hampshire.
Newport yachting center. Newport,
Rhode Island. I know that sounds fancy,
but it's a giant tent outside
in the parking lot, so
don't, don't be intimidated.
Come on down.
I need you to Caroline's on Broadway.
July 26th through the 29th. And, uh,
who out there is from Charlotte,
North Carolina, north cack,
a fucking lackey
motherfucker. Um, I actually,
we're in the process of booking a date
there on a weekend when the panthers have
a home game. So I'm going to go out
to a game, see Cam Newton, and uh,
by then my fucking act ought to
be, uh, about three quarters ready,
my special be about a month away
from coming out. So a bunch of dates,
Yadda, Yadda, Yadda. Please come
out and see me. Uh, once again,
thanks to everybody who's been listening
to the podcast, making donations, um,
you know, take advantage of some of the
advertising then I'm bringing to you.
You know, anybody who orders the flowers,
I really appreciate it. That is it.
That is all. Go fuck
yourselves. Don't take any shit.
Don't hang out with lesbians thinking
you're going to fuck them. Either.
Be Friends with them and trade
ratchet sets or fucking move on.
All right?
That is it.
God bless you and God bless
the United States of America.